Bioware has released a new trailer for  Mass Effect Andromeda that gives us a  brief look at the game's multiplayer I'm  Tony and this game spot news update is  out of this world the trailer is really  meant to show off some pre-order bonuses  but it does give us a glimpse at the  multiplayer which looks a lot like it  did in Mass Effect 3 with biotic powers  and a Krogan ground pound on display  that said the developers have stated  that multiplayer is much more mobile  this time as for those pre-order bonuses  ponying up for the game early gets you a  skin for rider a skin for the nomads and  a multiplayer booster pack Mass Effect  Andromeda launches for ps4 xbox one and  pc on March 21st if you're feeling rich  you can grab the deluxe or super deluxe  edition to get yourself the soundtrack  and some other bonuses we've got all the  details at gamespot so head over there  and make sure you're subscribed to keep  up with all the latest Mass Effect news  you